the green salon record of leadership
and a qualitative challenge of our
time as members of the new york on the
same time you already the seas that apa
it brings for building for sustainable
economies and stable competitively means
i am deeply convinced that this
agreement for  international
climate protection is important, but it
is also important for the
united nations, which you will lead until the end of
this year.
top twenty one is proof gets infected with
electrolysis motto global governance of
planet is netapp dream as some people
say
without the manager  in europe,
this agreement would not have existed and for
that, the prerequisites were that we
europeans were united, that we
speak with one voice and thus have a say in global
issues,
we understand today's act
today's decision as a
starting signal because we cannot stand still but
we have to approach  the
way we l  just as we produce
as we consume